[Musique]
avec des rassemblements Michel toujours
en hommage à Dominique Bernard le
professeur assassinat aras qui sont
poursuivis ce mardi dans les ivelines
nous étions hier à manilamo et à plaisir
mais c'est quasiment l'ensemble des
communes de 50 ans en ivine qui ont
organisé des rassemblements hier soir
les habitants d'élencour étaient appelés
à se mobiliser aux alentour de 18h sur
le parvis de l'Hôtel de Ville des
minutes de silence ont également été
observées ce mardi c'était le cas à MIDH
à trappe devant la mairie mais aussi à
coignir toujours à midi le rassemblement
s'est déroulé cette fois-ci à
l'intérieur de l'hôtel de ville
plusieurs dizaines d'habitants étaient
présents à chaque fois pour ces
ansommage même près de 300 personnes
pour la ville de trappe on a vu une
image s'afficher le verdict est tombé
pour le fichs qui a été arrêté vendredi
à Limet l'individu a été condamné à 6
mois de prison en ferme avec maintien en
détention par le tribunal correctionnel
de Versailles vendredit le même jour que
l'assassinat de Dominique Bernard haras
l'homme a été arrêté avec un couteau aux
abords du lycée orsé de Limet ce dernier
est connu des services de police pour au
moins CIN faits similaires des photos de
décapitation aurit été également été
retrouvé sur son portable en revanche
aucune infraction terroriste n'a été
retenue contre lui lors de son jugement
en comparution immédiate on va sortir un
peu de cette actualité difficile avec la
présence ce matin dans les ielines d'un
ministre ce matin le ministre du Travail
du plein emploi et de l'insertion
Olivier dusopt était à trrappe il est
venu au secteur d'action sociale
présenté le projet d'accompagnement
renforcé des bénéficiaires du RSA pour
favoriser la réinsertion professionnelle
parcours individualisé moins
d'interlocuteurs et plus de contact avec
les employeurs du territoire depuis
juillet 2023 4800 allocataires résidents
sur 50 ans livin expérimentent ce
nouveau dispositif jusqu'à fin 2024 on
écoute les réactions micro de Julien
lurois quand on regarde les chiffres au
niveau national on voit que sur les
1950000 allocataires du RSA 42 % sont au
RSA depuis plus de 7 ans et et nous
avons une difficulté de retour à
l'emploi je pense que dans une période
où le chômage baisse ou les entreprises
frais d'emploi où nous considérons que
tout le monde est employable c'est
important de tout mettre en œuvre pour
accompagner ce celles et ceux qui sont
les plus éloigné il y a plus de moyens
et il y a un partage des informations et
un partage des compétences et pour
l'interlocuteur pour celui qui est en
face de de ses collaborateurs et de Pôle
emploi et du département c'est très
apaisant parce qu'il a on lui fait son
guichet unique devant lui il a toutes
les compétences qui s'ouvrent un mot de
sport et de rugby il sont là Michel les
All Black sont dans les ivelines oui la
Nouvelle-Zélande va préparer toute cette
semaine sa demi-finale de Coupe du monde
à Croatie sur scène les blacks sont
arrivés hier soir et se sont entraînés
sur le terrain du stade municipal ils
affronteront l'Argentine ce vendredi
soir à 21h au Stade de France pour une
place en finale eux qui ont pour
objectif de soulever un 4e titre mondial
malheureusement pour le public et pour
vous he Grégory canalé tous les
entraînements vont se dérouler à huclos
je suis très déçu je suis très déçu de
pour pas pouvoir voir les All Black pour
terminer retour sur un événement s'est
déroulé à Montini le Bretonneux du 10 au
15 octobre c'était la 20e édition de la
Semaine du handicap à Montini le
Bretonneux la commune organisée à
nouveau de nombreux rendez-vous dont le
point d'org était le grand jeu défi en
famille le dimanche des sensibilisations
mais aussi du recrutement le vendredi 13
se tenait au sein de l'Hôtel de Ville un
forum du recrutement une dizaine
d'entreprises avaient fait le
déplacement avec plus d'une centaine
d'offres d'emploi à la clé sont des
personnes en situation de handicap qui
sont spécifiquement conviés à
l'événement euh
on est en partenariat avec Cap Emploi
Paul emploi et laagfip qui en amont donc
sélectionne des CV de personnes en
situation de handicap pour que cela
matche avec les différentes offres que
qu'ont les entreprises c'est très très
important parce que voilà nous aussi ça
veut dire que on peut servir à quelque
chose à la société voilà handicap ça
veut pas dire que comme moi
personnellement je le pensais je pensais
que handicap ça veut dire que c'est fini
le fait que ça soit vraiment un forum
accé en handicap pour le coup les
personnes sont un peu plus en
confiance et on voilà on a le temps de
parler un peu plus avec eux de les
rassurer aussi he puisque bah c'est vrai
que des fois c'est pas toujours simple
d'être confronté aussi à des
recrutements merci michaell et si vous
aussi près de chez vous vous êtes témoin
d'une actualité qui vous fait réagir
dans les evelines n'hésitez pas à la
partager sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hashtag 78 new